game two ahead between the twins and the
rays we're also honoring the 1991
twins world series win that came 30
years ago what an anniversary what a
reunion and what a ceremony we just saw
a five and four record he gets a lot of
chases on that splitter down and in and
that'll be a key for him tonight to move
that record to six and four
and a strikeout to start the ball game
yeah and that's exactly the pitch we
were talking about
popped up right side
polanco on the outfield grass
and maida has a quick one two three
first inning
right-hander michael walka making his
16th start of the season 21st overall
appearance looking to get things back on
track here
a high drive right center field and deep
kiermeyer looking up
and it's gone
kepler connects his 15th of the year on
the second pitch of the game
in waka's last start cedric mullins hit
the first pitch of the game for a home
run
[Music]
driven to center caremeyer back
off the wall rooker has another hit his
fifth of the series a double first and
third now four odd eyes
base hit left field it'll score rooker
and which ones jump out quickly two to
nothing
drown the line and a fair ball into the
corner
donaldson can't run well he'll score a
rise will be held it's another double
this time for rooker in a very quick
three to nothing lead
[Applause]
[Music]
drill oh what a stop by lau
and he throws low and troy keeps a foot
on the bank that might have been the
hardest hit wall of the inning wow
so those retired arrives scoring it's
four to nothing garber to third base but
that ball was
absolutely scorch
that's the left and deep to the corner
chased by rooker and
oh
rucker with a great diving catch on the
warning drag what a tremendous play by
rooker to end the inning
and that ball back a third backhanded
pick by wendell and he gets him on the
throw to first
nice play right there
if he doesn't make that play there's
another run
this one is
popped into short left
meadows
makes the catch to retire the side
two strike pitch is swung on a miss by
lau speaking of fantastic maida through
three scoreless
when the lead off man is out again
[Music]
arise with a deep drive to right and
it's long gone and arise skips his way
halfway up to first
that's the longest home run i think he's
ever hit
one out on the plaza
base in right field
garber will score
and it's seven to nothing
swinging this by choi and kenta maeda
having fun tonight as he twirls his
fourth consecutive
scoreless inning here's a rose arena he
has the only tampa bay hit
to maeda
to polanco
a double play
[Applause]
got him looking shaved the outside
corner a hit batter a single no damage
done nobody's touched second base yet
against kenta maeda
to the right field corner
and a fair ball so noah's going to try
for two rosarina's throw is not quite in
time
rocco baldelli loving every extra base
hit that cenote drives into the opposite
field
and a little ground ball
handy and field that takes care
of sevens
seven nothing minnesota
chopper to second
out there and a rise fires his throw to
first to get the double play
score it four five three
popped up
straight up in here
garver
went the catch and that wraps up the
sixth inning
six
shutout innings for kenta maeda brent
rooker drilled a double off the
centerfield fence his first time up
deep down the left field line and
gone a home run
rooker strikes again
his sixth of the year
that got out in a hurry
moved right into the barrel of brett
rooker's bat what a good-looking swing
he's got some pop and we'll be
interested to see how
garza jr looks here
uh didn't pitch at all last year
nice and on three pitches he picks up
his first twins strikeout
shifted perfectly
and another one two three inning for a
twin pitcher this time it's ralph carson
jr 2-0 cave
and a base hit left field cave against
the lefty
and he'll drive in a couple of runs
good advantage cave
sheriff struggling with his command a
little bit but still a tough assignment
for a left-handed batter and he comes
through
[Applause]
he pops one up
simmons retreats polanco coming in it'll
be angelton simmons he'll squeeze it and
ralph garza says thank you very much
six up six down in his twins debut well
the rays
will send jordan luplow
to the
mound deep down the left field line
and long gone
jeffers off the bench
joins the hit and home run parade
and he takes luplow deep
in the eighth very deep two strikes to
nelson cruz with two down on the night
chopper to short
and that wraps up a really fun night at
target field sure does
honoring the 91 team and the
2021 team
honored the 91 team by
pitching a shutout putting on quite a
hitting display